[Music]
hello there it's been 5 years since the
original Marvel Spider-Man released on
the PS4 and three since miles became
part of that spider family the next
installment of The Saga is coming to PS5
on October 20th and here's everything
you need to know before you play
Spider-Man 2 let's start with the story
here on Earth 1048 Spider-Man 2 is set
roughly 9 months after the tinkerer came
to town in miles's adventure or 19
months after the first time we filled
the boots of Peter Parker why is that
important well all because of the story
every event every plot point every fight
scene from back then matters in
Spider-Man 2 to help out with this I've
started releasing story breakdowns for
each of the games and the DLC too so
don't fret if you need a refresher I
have you covered the car plot to
Spider-Man 2 revolves around Norman
Osborne and his desire to save his son
Harry from a mysterious illness which
has already claimed the life of his wife
and by the looks of things the Venom
symbiote will be the Catal list of
Harry's survival elsewhere a new enemy
to this universe has arrived Craven the
hunter who sees New York as the perfect
playground to face off with the toughest
heroes and villains the world has to
offer meanwhile Peter Parker has access
to this new black suit which seems to be
corrupting him slowly and strangely at
the preview event Insomniac refused to
call this a symbiot suit and I don't
know why there will be a whole host of
other villains in the story but we'll
talk about that a little later next
let's have a look at the combat system
which has seen a bunch of updates and
upgrades miles and Peter are different
Spider-Man and they have different
abilities to level individually miles
has his unique bioelectric powers which
continue to evolve constantly and now
Peter has access to that symbiot suit
with a whole new set of moves to master
thanks to those tendrils of Venom then
on top of that the pair have a shared
upgrade tree for their tech-based powers
so whatever Peter unlocks is instantly
unlocked for Miles 2 and vice versa
the L1 and R1 buttons will control these
abilities with the left side
representing the powers of that specific
Spider-Man and the right side being the
tech upgrades available to both
Spider-Man 2 is completely a single
player game but there is a great twist
to that both Peter and miles are
playable at any point Spider-Man 2 uses
a quick swap mechanic to allow you to
main your favorite Spider-Man or keep
switching between the two as you see fit
this won't be possible 100% of the time
as some story missions and side missions
are only playable by one specific
Spider-Man for example High School
issues need to be solved by Miles the
rest of the time though it's up to the
player to decide who is their Spider-Man
oh and each time we switch a unique
animation will play out kind of like
those in GTA 5 what is more mind-blowing
is that the other Spider-Man will still
be getting on with crime fighting when
you're not controlling them it's
possible to bump into them in the
streets and even team up in a fight
amazing
another combat update is here for Spider
Sense the glowing light around a
Spider-Man's head as they feel imminent
danger in Spider-Man 2 this skill will
be used to warn players of unblockable
attacks shown in blue which Peter and
miles should Dodge whereas a red tingle
is a prompt to Parry the attack and keep
on swinging hay makers in return it's
only a subtle upgrade to the combat
system which should add a bunch of more
timing based variations to fights thanks
to the SSD inside the PS5 the instant
switching between Mars and Peter can be
evolved into fast travel anywhere at all
on the map and I mean anywhere after
unlocking areas of the world we can
simply click somewhere on the map at
random and a second later your chosen
Spider-Man is already there we have to
unlock this ability so it won't be there
from our first moment but what a cool
mechanic all the same this speed of
loading is probably why the PS4 version
is not possible this time around with
all this new real estate to explore we
need traversal options and Spider-Man 2
does not disappoint firstly our swinging
animation is now a little quicker
allowing us to travel a little faster
also around the world are catapult
points on rooftops which give Spider-Man
An Almighty speed boost n on immediately
and finally every spider suit has wings
gliding is now possible and to help out
there are wind traps and vents to be
flown through to add more speed to your
flight Spider-Man 2 is simply rapid with
a larger map a new progression system is
required that's where the district
system comes in the world is cut into
areas or Burrows if you prefer Each of
which have their own missions and
unlocks and once leveled up enough
that's when instant travel is unlocked
something to work for I guess Marvel
Spider-Man 2 continues to evolve its
island with additional peers spotted in
many trailers and newly constructed
buildings after the explosive events of
the Miles Morales story yet the map is
now twice the size of the original with
the addition of queens and Brooklyn
miles's Brooklyn Visions Academy is here
as to is Peter's old Stomp ground at
Midtown High the most alluring new
addition is the Coney Island fun fair
cuz I'm hoping for rideable roller
coasters thanks to the PS5 it's now
possible to increase the number of
civilians around the city both on foot
and in their vehicles increased detail
is everywhere including in high-rise
buildings people can be going about
their days inside their apartments and
we can see them through the windows New
York this time around is packed but it's
only New York when you hear hey I'm
walking here hey I'm walking here
I'm walking here we have a few reports
about the game length which states
Spider-Man 2 will be roughly the same
length as the first game that's
according to insomniac's Ryan Smith
which should put the main story at
around 15 to 20 hours in length to add
to that is all the side content and
dynamic events which are much more
plentiful this time around which could
add anything from 5 to 15 hours onto
that play time making the platinum
trophy around 30 hours to achieve how do
you feel about that does the length of a
game impact your enjoyment
every self-respecting Spider-Man fan
loves alternative suits and Spider-Man 2
does not let anyone down we've had a few
numbers confirmed by Insomniac we'll
have over 65 suits to unlock from
original designs call backs to the comic
books and of course the threads in
iconic movies like the symbiot suit from
the Ramy movies on top of that are
variant almost all suits have four color
palet swaps on offer so realistically
there are over 200 suits in this game
ranking them is going to be impossible
there is a little caveat to that
information which I can't decide is good
or bad news 10 suits are exclusive to
the deluxe version of the game which
cannot be unlocked in the standard
version I fully expect the possibility
of a paid upgrade ingame at a later date
but I thought you should know all the
same as some of these suits are straight
up fire arguably the best in the
game the number of villains confirmed in
Marvel Spider-Man 2 is jawdropping are
you ready for this we have venom Craven
the hunter lizard black cat the prowler
Kingpin Mr negative scorpion Tombstone
wrath and Taskmaster and fans are
predicting this chap here will be
confirmed to be Mysterio miles and Peter
are going to have their hands for
keeping this city under control but
there is actually a few more villains
here did you know there is a comic book
which acts as a prequel to The Event in
Spider-Man 2 here are a bunch of plot
points check back next week if you'd
like a real breakdown of this story
basically the Spider-Man men fight two
villains the tarantula who is yet
another Spider-Man but not a good one
like our heroes he's defeated and sent
to jail and the second villain is the
hood who commits petty theft to buy a
magical tablet that he's told can cure
his mother's cancer long story short
yeah it fails the real impact of This
Side Story is for Triple J J Jonah
Jameson has bought back The Daily Bugle
again after a heated argument with Mary
Jane making him effectively her boss in
Spider-Man 2 and Fin finally Peter is
confirmed to live in Aunt May's house
after her passing but is struggling to
pay the bills mainly because he's
decided to retrain as a teacher Peter
Parker is going to be a teacher I did
not see that one coming and to end let's
just finish on a bunch of really small
details confirmed about Marvel
Spider-Man 2 fall damage can be toggled
on and off in the settings should you
want a little more realism and gravitas
to your swinging then flick this switch
and Peter and Miles could be falling
harder than Gwen Stacy too soon my bad
for graphical options have been
confirmed all of which use rate tracing
for more realistic lighting and
Reflections above the standard 1080p we
have Dynamic 4K at 30 40 and 60 frames
per second depending on if you prefer
the visuals to take priority or the
fluidity of the movement and to my
surprise there is a 1440p mode with a
targeted 120 frames per second super
smooth in somniac have showcased their
Superior accessibility options for
gamers who want them ranging from
colored outlines of Heroes and villains
to the speed of battles and the reaction
times needed truly a game for anyone the
Dual sense controller is confirmed to
fully integrate haptics and force
feedback making triggers harder to push
when the character on screen is having a
tougher time I quite like the example
given of this as the massive belt HS
sending impactful reverberating ripples
through the Dual sense controller
haptics as the black suit Twitches
around Peter as does the Dual sense
controller oh it sounds good my voice is
really going now and I think that's
everything confirmed for Spider-Man 2 if
I've missed something let me know and
I'll pin your comment I'm Adam thank you
very much for watching you're awesome no
you're amazing no you're spectacular see
you